The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at OCW.MIT.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today's lecture is
on intermolecular interactions.
And it's really one of
these favorite topics
where I can say, well,
this is the origin of life.
How do gases actually condense?
And we can build a really,
really simple theory
for how gases condense
based on what we know,
based on second order
perturbation theory,
based on some hand-waving stuff.
And it really is
something from nothing.
But it's also an example of
what we do in physical chemistry
where we explain one phenomenon
by taking something that
seems to be unrelated and
building a model around it,
and explaining this
surprising thing.
And that's what's
going to happen today.
We'll talk more about that.
OK, now last time we talked
about wavepacket dynamics.
And so with wavepacket dynamics,
there is first the pluck.
How do you start the system
in some superposition
of eigenstates?
And then there's the evolution
of the pluck, which is usually
some kind of particle-like state
that follows Newton's laws.
The center of the wavepacket
follows Newton's laws
for the position
and the momentum.
But if you make a wavepacket
in a real molecule,
the molecule is going to be
not a harmonic oscillator.
There will be anharmonic effects
which causes the wavepacket
to de-phase, but the
center of the wavepacket
continues to move as if it
were in a simple potential.
And it can de-phase, and
rephase, and all sorts
of complicated stuff.
And that can be
very interesting.
Now, when you take this step
from a diatonic molecule
to a polyatomic
molecule, you have
3n minus 6 oscillators
cohabiting in the same house.
And they're going to interact.
And so if you start
a wavepacket on one
Franck-Condon
bright mode because
of anharmonic interactions
handled by perturbation theory,
between modes you start to get
this wavepacket leaking out
into other modes.
And so the expectation
value is going
to exhibit an oscillating
time dependence associated
with the bright mode and
some of the dark modes
that are anharmonically
coupled to the bright mode.
And it can get
pretty complicated.
But you can understand
all of it because you
have perturbation theory.
And so you can say, OK
this time the wavepacket--
some amplitude of the
initial wavepacket
is transferred to
a different mode.
And when does that happen?
Stationary phase.
It happens at a
particular geometry.
And so you can be
asking, OK, when is
this excitation transferring?
How strongly?
This is a very, very
complete picture.
And it's very much like
classical mechanics
because it's localized.
Then we talked
about Landau-Zener.
And the Landau-Zener is
basically a simple idea
that you also understand
from real life.
And it has to do with how does
a wavepacket jump from one
potential surface to another?
And again, it's
stationary phase.
At the internuclear distance
of the curve crossing,
the wavepacket has
to decide which
curve it's going to follow.
And it depends on the
velocity of the packet
at the curve crossing and the
difference in slopes of the two
paths it has to choose between.
And all of this is very simple.
Now, I am trying to create
an exam problem which
is related to Landau-Zener.
And this is hard.
But if I succeed, then
you can expect to see it.
The last thing I talked
about the last lecture
was the Zewail
pump-probe experiments.
And this is a beautifully
graphical picture
of how do you create
something and then
probe what's happening.
And again, I hope
that I can come up
with something pictorial for
the exam on the Zewail pump.
OK, now before I talk about
intermolecular interactions,
I want to do a little bit
of tying up loose ends.
You know about non-degenerate
perturbation theory.
Now there's another kind of
perturbation theory called
degenerate perturbation theory.
And this is when non-degenerate
perturbation theory
fails because H i j
over E i 0 minus E j 0
is greater than one.
Well then you've got a problem.
You can't use ordinary
perturbation theory.
You have to diagonalize.
You diagonalize it
two by two or you
diagonalize all of the little
cases where this is violated.
That's called degenerative
perturbation theory.
And there is a little
bit of extra recipe
for how do you put information
about remote states
into the part of the
Hamiltonian you diagonalize?
That's called a Van
Vleck transformation,
and I'm not going
to talk about it.
But basically you fix things
up by diagonalizing two
by two or three by three.
And then do ordinary
perturbation theory.
And then there's variational.
The variational
model is something
we've used mostly in a
minimum basis set for talking
about the atomic molecules.
And in the variational
model, we minimize energies
by optimizing
mixing coefficients.
Now, perturbation theory is
implicitly an infinite basis.
Usually the infinity
doesn't matter
because the interesting
stuff comes in
from relatively
low-lying levels.
And the infinite number
of very far away levels
just modifies the energy
levels a little bit,
and you don't have
to worry about it.
The variational method, you
choose your own basis set.
Now, the choice of
basis set is frequently
dictated by convenience.
And the basis set is often not
very large or not orthonormal.
And so there are
problems with how
do we deal with
basis functions which
are not orthonormal, especially
not orthogonal to each other?
And there is a
transformation that you
can do to make that work out.
I mean, the problem
is basically--
the secular equation is this
for the variational method.
And this is the overlap matrix.
And the overlap matrix
is not the unit matrix.
We have what's called the
generalized variational
calculation.
And there are methods
for handling that.
And I have often introduced
those methods on a final exam.
Those are just statements.
OK, so variational
is not guaranteed
to give the exact answer.
And it can't if you don't
use an infinite basis.
Perturbation theory implicitly
uses this infinite basis.
And you should feel
confident that you're getting
close to the right answer.
And you can know what sort
of errors you're making.
OK, yes?
AUDIENCE: When you go
to very high orders
in perturbation theory,
your convergence
is not necessarily better--
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
AUDIENCE: --on the
real solutions.
PROFESSOR: OK, but that's--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
when to cool it?
PROFESSOR: This is-- the
problem there is that you cannot
include correlation in
perturbation theory.
And so there are
things that are outside
of the network of things
that I've described.
And so correlation effects
where the particles
can move in some way that
they know about each other.
That's very difficult to build
in via perturbation theory.
But when we don't
have correlation,
length perturbation
theory makes an error.
And you know how
big that error is.
OK, and then we know that we
can diagonalize the matrix
by some kind of
unitary transformation.
And the columns of T dagger
are the eigenvectors.
And the rows of T
are the inverse--
rows of T dagger or the
columns of T are the inverse.
And so if you want to
make a wavepacket where
you have some additional
state to equal 0,
you want to express that
as a linear combination
of eigenstates.
And this sort of transformation
provides that information
if you know how to use it.
And you can get
approximations to all
of these elements of T
dagger from non-degenerate
perturbation theory.
And on the second exam
that was one of the things
you didn't do very well on.
And so you can see that again.
All right.
OK, so now we're going to
talk about intermolecular
interactions.
And up until now,
we've been talking
about isolated molecules.
And you have a lot of insights
about how isolated molecules
work, or at least
what kind of stuff
you need to be able to make
predictions about isolated
molecules.
And perturbation theory
is a very important tool
in building that insight.
In almost every problem which is
not an exactly soluble problem,
perturbation theory gives you
at least a hand-waving argument
for what's going on.
Everything we did
with LCAO-MO is really
based on perturbation theory,
or at least the interpretations,
especially when you go from
homonuclear to heteronuclear.
And when we talk about what
various orbitals look like
and why they look that way.
OK, so perturbation theory can
also be used to talk about--
we have two particles,
A and B. And we
have the origin of coordinates.
And so this is the
coordinate for A,
and this is the
coordinate for B.
And this is the
interatomic coordinate.
And so we're interested
in what happens
as a function of this
interatomic distance.
And can we use
perturbation theory
to be able to say
something about that?
And the answer is you betcha.
Because basically we understand
how these two molecules work.
And so we have to somehow
build in some insight
into what is the
interaction between these,
and then use perturbation
theory to quantify it.
OK, now this is
a situation where
we're going to say atoms A
and B are our field shell,
or whatever you want to call it.
They don't need to
make another bond.
They're not going to
bond to each other.
There's no covalent
bond between A and B.
There is no charge on A and
B. There is no donor/acceptor.
All of the things
that we can understand
by looking at
individual systems,
they are all turned off.
These molecules do
have energy levels.
And so if we could
find some way to talk
about the weak
interaction between them,
well then we have the basis
for perturbation theory.
Because we have weak and
we have energy levels
that we know for
the two molecules.
And so if we're going to
do perturbation theory
it'll be second order
perturbation theory
because we are going to be
interested in how interaction
of A with B causes
excited states of B to mix
into B, and vice versa.
And so one of the things you
know about perturbation theory,
if you're talking about the
ground state of a system
and you do perturbation
theory, what happens?
What happens to
the energy levels?
I mean, you have--
for second order
perturbation theory--
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: Everything
gets-- things
can increase or decrease.
The H term gets squared.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Some
[INAUDIBLE] information.
But depending on whether
a level that's lower--
PROFESSOR: But if we're talking
about the ground state--
AUDIENCE: If it's that ground
state it has to go down.
PROFESSOR: Right.
And so that's the key.
We know that if we're going to
do second order perturbation
theory and we're going
to be asking questions
about molecules in
their ground state,
they're going to be
stabilized by interaction
with other molecules.
It doesn't matter,
as long as there's
no bonding interactions,
or very strong short range
interactions, this
sort of a problem
is guaranteed to give
stabilization of the ground
state of the system.
And that's really a
surprise, because--
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You're
treating the system
as though it has like a ladder
of energies and everything
is already at its lowest?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Well, OK-- you know,
I'm not allowed
to talk about statistics.
I can't, actually.
Because we do it--
we now do some statistical
mechanics in 560.
So you know a little bit.
And you know that the molecules
like to be in the lowest energy
levels.
And so we have these ground
state molecules in a gas.
And we understand they're
isolated properties,
or we could understand.
And what happens here?
Somehow there's
interactions between them.
And now first order
perturbation theory,
you're allowed to have a sign.
But you're allowed to have
a sign for diagonal elements
of the perturbation operator.
OK, so we'll just
continue with this.
So we want to talk
about Hamiltonian
for the system, which is
the Hamiltonian for particle
A, the Hamiltonian
for particle B,
plus some interaction
term between A and B.
OK, now the typical interaction
between two particles
is a dipole-dipole interaction.
If molecules have
dipole moments,
then we already know
something about what they
want to do with each other.
And from electricity
and magnetism--
we know this isn't
quantum mechanics--
we know that we can
write a general formula
for the dipole-dipole
interaction.
So that's the
general formula for
the dipole-dipole interaction.
And it's a little
more complicated
than you would like
because there's two terms.
And this one is kind
of a puzzling term
because you're projecting a
dipole on the interatomic axis.
And so we'd like to be
able to simplify this.
And we can simplify
it by simply drawing
some vectors corresponding
to the dipole moment.
And so we have the dipoles
oriented like that.
Or we have the dipoles
oriented like this,
or like this and like that.
Now, this is a reduction.
You know, these are
the simplified terms
where these guys are
irrelevant or at least you
don't have to worry
about the projections.
And we know that this is
an attractive interaction,
this is an attractive
interaction.
This is repulsive and
this is repulsive.
And we know also by
plugging into the formulas,
we know that the energy for this
one is minus mu-A mu-B over two
pi epsilon 0 R cubed.
And this is minus
the same stuff,
except a four in
the denominator.
So that means it's less
attractive than this one.
Minus means attractive.
And then we have two
terms that resemble these
except they're repulsive.
So there's four terms.
So there's two terms
that are attractive
and two terms that
are repulsive.
And they come in pairs, one
positive and one negative.
And so you might naively
say well, you can't win.
If the particles are randomly
distributed and randomly
oriented, there will be
no stabilization, even
with dipoles.
But that's not true
because the molecules
try to find an
orientation which is
more stable than the sum of the
energies without the dipoles.
And so maybe we
could draw a picture
and try to figure out,
well, how that would be.
So does anybody want to give
me guidance to a picture
showing, let's say,
four dipoles oriented
in the corner of a square?
And what would be the
stable arrangement
for four dipoles oriented
on the corners of a square?
OK, right?
So we have two
attractive interactions,
two more attractive
interactions,
and then there are repulsive
interactions this way.
But we have nearest neighbors.
And they're stronger than
the repulsive interactions.
And so for one
layer, that can win.
Now, we have another
layer of four dipoles.
And if that layer is--
so we have another layer, and
there will be four of them.
And what would happen?
What would be the
stable arrangement
if I have a dipole
above this one?
Is it going to be this way?
Right.
And so the next layer, all
the dipoles are reversed.
And so you can conceive
of an arrangement
where the dipoles would adopt
a more stable arrangement.
And statistical mechanics, or
whatever you want to call it,
guides that.
And so we can say, all
right, the ensemble
of dipoles interacting
with each other
can arrange to be
energetically stabilizing.
And so we can reduce the
problem to just one picture,
say this type or that
dipole-dipole arrangement,
and do second order
perturbation theory.
And that will be an overestimate
of the stabilization.
But it will be proportional
to the stabilization.
And so we can get what
we need for a very
complicated infinite
number of particle problem.
OK, another thing that
I want to ask you,
suppose you have two particles
and they come together.
And so they come together
with some kinetic energy.
And they can't get rid
of that kinetic energy,
so they come apart.
Now, if you have
three particles,
if something drives them
together by mutual attraction,
then one particle can take
away the excess energy.
You can end up leaving the
two particles together.
That's how you make liquids.
So the driving force
for the attraction
between atoms or
molecules is somehow
related to what we're
going to drive here.
And that is the only way
you make liquids from gases.
And it's really
strange because we're
going to be talking about
energy levels and interactions
between molecules,
and somehow coming up
with a picture that leads
to universal attraction
between molecules
that are not charged,
not reactive, not anything.
And they will always
attract each other.
And that's the first step
towards making liquids.
OK, now the important
thing in all of this
is that the
interactions are small
compared to the energy levels
of the individual molecules.
And so that's why we're
doing perturbation theory.
OK, so in perturbation
theory we have an H 0.
And the H 0 is--
I've got to make sure I
use consistent notation.
Well, I already see
I have inconsistent
notation in my notes.
But anyway, OK, so we
have the Hamiltonian
is the individual
system Hamiltonians,
the sum of the two.
And the first order term is VAB.
And so whenever we
can separate a system,
we know that the zero
order wave functions
are products of the
eigenfunctions of HA and HB.
And the energy levels of 0
[INAUDIBLE] energy levels
are sum of the energy
levels for HA and HB.
So we know that we can write
H 0 psi A alpha psi B alpha.
So this guy--
HA operates on psi A and
treats this as a constant.
HB operates on psi B and
And when you do that, what
you discover is that we get--
OK, so these are
our energy levels.
And these are our
basis functions.
And we are off to the races.
So this is E 0.
And this is psi
0 for the system.
OK, now the first thing we do in
perturbation theory is we say,
let's look for the first order
correction of the energy.
That's the diagonal matrix
element of the H1 term, this.
So suppose we do have dipole
moments on both particle A
and particle B
So that's the
first order energy.
Well, this is just the
dipole-dipole interaction.
And so we can take
the reduced formula.
We're just going to regard VAB
as mu A dot mu B over R cubed.
And so the energy is minus one
over two pi epsilon 0 R cubed.
I left out the two pi
epsilon 0 on this formula.
And so skipping a
couple of steps,
we have mu A mu B, the
expectation value of these.
So if there's a
dipole-dipole interaction,
there will be a first
order correction term.
And keep in mind that
these guys can have signs.
And that sign does appear in
the first order correction
to the energy.
But that's basically these
pictures we drew here.
We have a dipole
pointing this way,
we have a dipole
pointing that way.
That's repulsive.
And that's all-- so
there's no surprises here.
OK, but the important
thing is that the energy--
If we have two
molecules with dipoles,
we get an interaction energy
that we can calculate.
But the interesting
thing is going
to be when we have
molecules where at least one
of the molecules
doesn't have a dipole.
Then we're getting
into territory
that we didn't
think we understood.
But we're continuing
with the problem
where we do have dipoles.
I just want to make sure that--
yeah, OK.
So for the second order
correction to the lowest energy
level, we have the sum over m,
which is two quantum numbers.
And m is not equal
to the 0-0 state.
Alpha is not 0, beta is
not 0 sum over everything
except the ground state.
And what we have is an integral
of psi m 0 star VAB psi 0 0
d tau squared over
then E 0 0 minus E 0 m.
Standard formula for second
order variation theory.
This is the ground state.
This is some excited state.
This is negative.
This is squared.
And this is squared.
So this overall
correction is negative.
Now we can unpack
all this and we
can write the various terms
in more instructive form.
And what we'll have in the
denominator will be E 0--
well, E A 0 minus E A alpha
plus E B 0 E 0 E minus E B beta.
Now we can rearrange that so we
have E 0 A plus E 0 B minus E A
alpha plus E B beta.
So we have the ground state
energy and the known excited
state energies.
And there is the
difference between these.
So that part is simple.
And the matrix element also
simplifies to the product
of the dipole moment.
OK, now suppose--
I just want to
make sure that I'm
doing this in the order
it appears in the notes.
Suppose mu A is not 0
and mu B is equal to 0.
OK, well then all these
formulas go out the window
because nominally we
think well, this B
doesn't have a dipole moment.
But suppose we have a particle
B in an electric field.
The electric field
will polarize B.
And if we have molecule A, which
has a dipole moment, near B,
it will also polarize B. And
second order perturbation
theory tells us
how to handle that.
And so we get a
formula, a second order
correction to the energy B. And
we call this B comma induction.
And that's going to be
mu A squared over four pi
squared epsilon 0 squared
R to the six times
sum beta not equal to 0 of
the squared matrix element
integral psi B star beta mu
B psi B 0 d tau B squared
over E B 0 minus E B beta.
Now, I just told you
that the dipole moment--
the permanent dipole
moment for particle B is 0.
But this is not the expectation
value of the dipole moment.
This is an off-diagonal matrix
element of the dipole moment.
This is the transition dipole.
Transition between v equals 0--
well, between the
ground state of B
and some excited state, the
beta, excited state of B. Well,
we can write something
like that because we
know for all molecules
there are transitions, which
are electric dipole allowed.
Now they could be
between the ground state
and an electronically
excited state or the ground
state and a vibrationally
excited state.
So we know something
about these:
we know the rules for
when they're not 0.
And this is a perfectly
reasonable thing
because it says this is
related to the transition of--
the intensity of the
observable transition.
And this should
really start to make
you a little bit appreciative
of perturbation theory.
Because we're taking something
which you can observe,
a transition
strength, and using it
to describe an interaction
between two molecules.
So it's a relationship between
two apparently unrelated
phenomena.
Physical chemistry
is full of that.
You build a model.
And the model is telling
you that certain things
are related.
And how are they related?
Well, they're related by
one over R to the sixth.
They're related by the
strength of the dipole on one,
the permanent dipole on
one, and some transition
intensity-derived
quantity on the other.
Isn't that neat?
And since the dipole--
we say well, this is a
dipole-dipole interaction.
And the mu A, the dipole on
A, is inducing a dipole on B.
It's not inducing anything.
It's using transition dipoles.
But it's creating something that
looks like a permanent dipole.
And you have
dipole-dipole interaction.
But the only difference is that
it's one over R to the sixth
because it's an induced dipole.
OK, so we're using transition--
well, electric dipole
transition moments.
(There used to be two erasers!)
So these electric dipole
transition moments
play the role of producing
a dipole that can
interact with the other dipole.
And so-- well, do we need this?
Well, we don't really.
If you had dipoles,
then the interaction
would be one over R cubed.
But if one of the dipoles
is 0, then the interaction
is one over R to the sixth.
And it's one over R
to the sixth times
the permanent dipole of one and
this thing from perturbation
theory, which is the
induced dipole of the other.
Suppose mu A equals
0 and mu B equals 0.
Will the particles
interact with each other?
Will they attract each other?
And the answer is yes.
And it's going to be an
induced dipole-induced dipole
interaction.
Which, now since most people who
write for general science have
no clue about what
quantum mechanics is,
they will talk about all
sorts of fanciful things--
you get an institute--
an instantaneous fluctuation
on one particle which
creates an instantaneous
fluctuation
on the other particle, and
bam, you've got stabilization.
Well, yeah, maybe.
But you know, this is a
simple perturbation theory.
And so I don't really need to
actually write out everything.
Because one, you do that and
you include the second order
perturbation expression for
particle A and particle B,
you get a term that
looks just like this.
It has one over R to the sixth.
But it now involves
transition moments, particle A
and particle B--
nothing new.
You don't have to
induce anything more.
You don't get another
factor of one over R cubed.
You've already got the
one over R to the sixth.
So I'm going to
skip a lot of steps
because the notes are
really clear in there.
And we don't have a
whole lot of time.
And so I'm just going to
write down the result.
And now the name of this term
is called dispersion, or London
because a fellow by the name
of London invented this.
And the energy level formula
for this correction term
is one over four pi
squared epsilon 0 squared
R to the sixth.
And then this sum of alpha
equals one beta equals one
to infinity.
In other words, not alpha
equals 0, not beta equals 0.
And then--
Sorry about that.
So we have a numerator, which
is the squared transition
moment between the 0 level of
particle A and the alpha level
and the 0 level of B
and the beta level.
We have the energy
of the ground state
and we have the energy
of these excited states.
All of this stuff, you
know or at least you
can parametrize it in
terms of this strength
of our transition.
And there is an explicit formula
that relates the dipole moment
to the intensity depending on
what kind of experiment you do.
So I'm not going to
take you through that.
But you know you can measure
the intensity, the molar
absorptivity, or whatever you
want that is related to this.
So these are
experimentally observable.
These are experimentally
observable.
And usually this
infinite sum is dominated
by the lowest allowed transition
from the ground state.
And that can be an
electronic transition
or a vibrational transition.
So for our homonuclear
molecule, there
isn't going to be an allowed
vibrational transition.
So nitrogen and oxygen cannot
talk to each other through
transition dipole--
vibrational transition dipoles
because the dipole moment
is not dependent on
[INAUDIBLE] but they
have electronic transitions.
And so there is
this electronic-- as
opposed to a vibrational
polarizability of the two.
And that's what gives rise to
attraction between N2 and O2,
or N2 and N2.
So everything is
knowable and predictable.
And even though the
perturbation's sum is infinite,
and even though we've made a
gross approximation and say,
well, we're just interested
in this sort of an interaction
or this sort of an
interaction, and we
know that the true
interaction will
be less because there will
be an average over all
of the random orientations.
But there's going to be
a lowest energy picture.
And you can get that from
statistical mechanics.
And so you can do the
configurational average
over all possible orientations
of all of the interacting
particles.
And you can calculate this.
So that's beyond the
level of this course.
But the engine of the
calculation is this formula.
So molecules are polarizable.
They react to an
external electric field.
And there are several
ways you can describe
the defined polarizability.
One is to say well
the polarizability--
let's call it alpha--
is equal to the
second derivative
of the energy with respect
to the electric field.
But the polarizability,
you know,
you also get from
perturbation theory.
And so each of these
terms or the energy
is associated with
the interaction
of a dipole with
an electric field
is the electric field
times the dipole.
And so we have
electric field squared.
We take the second
derivative of that.
And we've got back to this.
So now here we come
with intuition.
If I asked you to tell
me the van der Waals
or the dispersion interaction
between helium and helium,
and compare that
to xenon to xenon,
would you be able to tell me?
So which one is stronger?
Which one-- which pair of
inert gases is stickier?
AUDIENCE: Xenon.
PROFESSOR: Xenon, right.
Why?
Because the energy denominator
for the first excited state
is much lower for
xenon than for helium.
OK, what about large molecule
versus small molecule?
Do I need to provide a hint?
3n minus six.
The more vibrational
modes, the more transitions
are available for polarization.
And so again, now we're
talking about molecules
which can be floppy.
And the floppier the molecule--
that means they have low
frequency vibrations--
you can polarize the
daylights out of them.
And so large molecules are
really sticky, stickier
than inert gases.
Because you have this
dispersion interaction
that brings them together.
And once they're together,
then they can do magic.
But the thing that drives the
condensation, or the formation
of droplets, or whatever, is
this dispersion interaction.
And it's universal.
Every pair of molecules or atoms
is going to attract each other.
And the strength is
something that you
can rate in terms
of what you know
about atomic and
molecular properties.
And isn't that neat?
Because you're
saying the viscosity,
or whatever it is, the property
of a gas, all of those things
are related to the properties
of the individual atoms
or molecules embedded
in perturbation theory.
This is why I think
perturbation theory is
so wonderful, because it enables
you to relate different things.
And even if you're
not going to evaluate
the magnitudes of
the terms, you can
make comparisons which are
always going to be right.
And that's kind of wonderful.
I mean, you don't have
to use the equations.
Or you just know that these
particles will attract
each other and the
driving force is either
a permanent or an
induced dipole.
And the induced dipole
will be strong if you
have a strong transition
to a low-lying state,
or a lot of strong transitions
to a lot of low-lying states
as you have in big molecules.
OK, so I'm not positive what I'm
going to talk about on Friday.
It's probably going
to be photochemistry.
But I may panic and
do something else.
OK, I'll see you Friday.